let me introduce our marvel
I'm very here too
talking because they have a lot of
important things to say as I introduce
him they'll come up here and take their
seats and then we'll get the panel
discussion going don carter is an
alumnus of our school of architecture he
became a very prominent practicing
architect as a principal at the urban
design associates in pittsburgh a
world-renowned firm for their work in
urban planning and design and he retired
as the president of urban design
associates recently we were very very
pleased to be able to coax him back to
Carnegie Mellon where he now serves as
the David Lewis director of urban design
and regional engagement and as director
of the remaking cities Institute which I
mentioned to you before don carter would
you please join me up here and i'm very
pleased to introduce to you also a
distinguished alumnus here from here on
mumbai parag parekh who is a practicing
architect he received his master's
degree in architecture from the from
Carnegie Mellon and returned here to
work in what was his father's from JP
parekh and son architects you may know
it is JP B which is done some very
important buildings here in Mumbai and
they continue to do some excellent work
one of their focus focuses has been on
sustainable development as well as
technical excellence and pairing is a
perfect panelist to join us here tonight
pyrite Pericles tomioka understand when
you buy a question particularly designed
for you as I mentioned it in the end the
introduction you have been practicing
architect for most of your career and
now you come back to the other side as a
teacher I'd be I think we'd all be very
interested in your observations
patient's about what you think
architecture students need to be
learning what they need to know to be
effective urban designers and architects
in the future Thank You Jerry and I'm so
glad to be here this is my first visit
to India my firm is international and we
actually have two projects ongoing right
now we have a project in jamnagar and
Gujarat 4s are designing a new town next
to one of their oil refineries and we
have a project at ludhiana in the Punjab
for REO which is a real estate
development firm both of those projects
are about three to four thousand housing
units and so I've had a lot of staff
here for the last three or four years
but this is my first visit and they said
I would really enjoy it and I certainly
have enjoyed it as Jerry said i have
worked 36 years in my firm starting as a
regional farm and then growing to an
international firm as we've said here
and about three or four years ago i
started thinking about whether i would
take the invitation of Carnegie Mellon
and given to me was to teach part time
on campus and I well I've never taught
but I've certainly practiced and I've
done a lot of work and the experience I
have probably would be helpful for
students so I thought it would just be a
part-time professor and then the job
came up for being the director to
remaking cities Institute so I very
boldly wrote a manifesto for what urban
designers need to know kind of what i
called the six essential practice
elements of urban design and they are
number one and most important was public
participation public engagement a second
one was engaging major stakeholders that
it's different than public participation
I'll talk about each of these a little
bit I just wanted to get all six out the
third one is working in
multidisciplinary teams and having been
a graduate of Carnegie Mellon I've
already experienced what that means
fourth one is about respecting context
and heritage where you practice
a fifth one is sustainable design which
is what our topic is here tonight but
it's what architects and urban designers
need to know and the last element is
implementation got to get something done
so you just don't do a plan without
knowing who's going to carry out the
plan where the money is going to come to
come from and what do you start with
first and just a little bit about each
of those the public participation is
very interesting and I'm teaching an
urban seminar and two-thirds of my
students are either from China or India
and it's not as if China or India are
known for their public engagement in
public planning processes and these
young students are just hungry for this
information and I I start off the class
by giving them a quote from Thomas
Jefferson about public participation one
of the great founders of our Republic I
know of no depository of the ultimate
powers of society but the people
themselves and if we think them not
enlightened enough to exercise their
control with a wholesome discretion the
remedy is not to take the discretion
from them but to inform their discretion
so public participation is also an
educational process engagement of major
stakeholders is is kind of what is
happening in China and India now the
government major developers major
corporations they're the ones that make
these decisions they also must be
included it's not as if the public is
the only source of it so you I say to
the students you must engage those
people as well the multidisciplinary
teams that means sociologists market
consultants ecologists historic
preservation people civil engineers a
whole range of people and what I point
out to them is the architect and urban
designer is the person has to lead this
team so you better know what those
fields are about and what they can
contribute to your project the fourth
being context and heritage and this is
something particularly working on in
ludhiana right now in which we're
working with regional architectural
forms rather than importing a new
from Europe or the united states or
somewhere else and that's kind of an
alien concept too because of as as you
well know a lot of the development india
is using forms of development that
aren't necessarily indigenous to this
region and we believe very strongly that
the thousands of years of tradition of
any city or culture should be retained
sustainable design I think goes with
without too much emphasis now because
that's what we'll be talking about
tonight but that's everything from green
buildings which broad is working on to
whole regional planning process around
water resources and things like that and
the last thing is implementation is
focused basically where's the money
coming from who's going to do it and did
my young employees at my firm and the
students I'm teaching I think they
really get that and they commit to it
this new generation really believes and
some of the things we're talking about
and the students from China and India
want to take this back and to make a
difference when they're there and i
quote a Native American proverb to them
that they find very emotional moment
when when we talk about this and this is
the quote treat the earth well it was
not given to you by your parents it was
loaned by your children we do not
inherit the earth from our ancestors we
borrow it from our children and they
really get that message that's great
thanks I hope all all your students for
paying attention Eric that the word
sustainability is used very frequently
today are sustainable to as an adjective
I wonder if you could help us early on
here to find a sustainable building is
and maybe give us a sense of how a
sustainable sustainable building differs
from not sustainable buildings or
buildings that we know in the best
before I start thanks a lot dr. Cohen
sreenivas for having us having me here
it's a great honor to be part of this
panel discussion so sustainability if
you look at what is sustainability I
think it is a relationship between two a
complex living systems I mean humans and
other living systems so the nature of
building activity itself has an impact
on the environment so just to put it
very simply because it's a buzz word
sustainability is about a being a
sustainable design of a sustainable
building is about design about building
and operating a building which has a
minimum effect on the environment in
this entire lifespan it's not just the
act of designing a building because all
through the process of actually
realizing the building and then
operating there is an effect on the
environment sustainable building
practices look at the entire life span
right from design to operation and so we
have at Carnegie Mellon the building
performance unit I mean we in our
practice in Mumbai we look at the same
approach that that we learnt there which
is a holistic approach to designing
buildings it is not looking in
individual systems and getting the best
of energy-efficient equipment and trying
to make sustainable buildings but it's
about buildings where all systems have
an inter where you can see the effect of
a system on the other system for example
when you choose a building envelope for
you choose a material what would be the
effect on the cooling and the lighting
lives a glazing system design whether it
will deliver or whether we just talked
to the lighting system and as soon as
you have daylight whether the lighting
system will turn off or dim so it's
about integrating all systems and seeing
the effect of one on the other that's
what differentiates largely a
sustainable building from a normal
building
the approach largely guides you know
whether you take a holistic approach or
an integrated approach to design or you
choose technologies and n fit into
design to achieve a particular rating or
to make them green buildings this is the
large in general difference the
advantage in sustainable buildings is
you have aesthetics and sustainable
criterias complementing each other there
is no there is no debate about form or
function both become justified on their
own so therefore it has helped us here
in projects where we've been able to do
sustainable buildings you can't do it in
all projects in Bombay there but where
we have that the it's it's easy to talk
about both form and function in the same
blend let's talk about Mumbai let's make
this specific but just a little context
first it's already the case of course
that the world's larger urban areas are
suffering now in terms of being of
coping with providing city services to
its citizens to providing a quality of
life which is tolerant a lot of people
Mumbai is I believe the sixth largest
city in the world was something like 20
million people was that right it's huge
it's challenging as the president is
though the future is going to be much
more challenging because the cut the
world continues to urbanize at a very
rapid pace and 20 million will not be a
surprise or strange will be many many
cities that have been larger so there's
some urgency to figuring out what
sustainable urban design means and
implementing it okay what that is
context let's talk about about
what do you see is the challenges and
how do we go about addressing them and
this is a question for both not just I
think India as well I think the
diagnosis is well known what we have
here is a situation where we're
depleting natural resources deforesting
we're drawing down the aquifers we're
expanding and urbanization without
planning projects can pop up almost
anywhere you have problems of public
sanitation multiple ownership of
properties is very hard to assemble
things and in my view is an architect
I've seen in the last 15 to 20 years not
only in in India but in China and in the
Middle East importation of architectural
and urban design models that we in the
West have rejected that we're done in
the 70s and 80s this kind of sprawl auto
oriented development and you're exactly
right about the population and we're
talking right now say thirty percent
I've the last figure thirty percent of
the population of India isn't as urban
for a population of 1.1 1.2 billion but
by 2030 it will be a population of 1.5
billion and fifty percent of that will
be urban and they will by that time
India will have been exceeding China and
population will be the largest
population in the world so the explosive
growth is going to be something very
difficult to deal with so what do we do
and it's not as if India is not thinking
about it I mean a month ago almost to
the day Prime Minister Singh opened up
the tenth Delhi what's it called the
Delhi sustainable development summit
talking about and something that Prague
and I've already talked about today you
have this sustainable development and we
think about his physical development but
he was saying our country cannot just
deal with climate control and
sustainable development with also not
talking about sustainable development
social terms because we've got this
incredible poverty and this kind
a twenty percent of the people in India
live in those so-called slumps and maybe
Mumbai might be double that in
percentage it might be forty percent
living these slums so it's one thing to
talk about green buildings and green
roofs it's another thing to say what
might you do about it now I have some
things on my talk about but I think
parag wanted their way em and some of
the issues so we can get all the bad
stuff out first today in Mumbai and as
they say is largely in India there is a
large shift in lifestyle the economic
conditions are improving across cities
and and enroll of economics and by by
this what happens is once the rural
lifestyle which traditions on
traditional fuel systems or energy
systems starts changing towards an urban
lifestyle which we within the systems we
rely on our all natural resources to
heat and cool our buildings and will be
not so this shift is causing more and
more demands on energy and the resulting
issues of emissions almost ninety
percent of an energy in a commercial
building goes in just heating and
cooling and residential building is
almost sixty percent so what has worked
in the past is is is looking at
adaptations of green buildings and
trying to mimic them or trying to adapt
them will no longer be applicable on a
larger scale because they're they're
fairly resource demanding and V as a
country cannot afford that kind of
consumption so we will have to go back
you've seen projects designed by us
where we have to go back to the first
principles of design look at look at
design solutions which are context-based
which which are which are based on
considering cooling criterias or natural
phenomenons not just mechanical so this
is the kind of approach that will will
shift in in terms of doing sustainable
buildings to meet this growths that is
happening because no longer can we just
buy more glass which is energy
just buy units which you know consume
less power because that is all
resource-hungry we need to go back to
our traditional you know solar shading
devices use control facades so that we
designed more for the context and that
is will be what we feel addressing these
issues because more and more is the
demand yes this parado what a well just
cut your arms of Smart Growth the
principles of smart growth is designed
for people not automobiles to be
sensitive to nature to bring nature back
into the city there's a whole national
international movement now is to is to
bring nature back into the city or at
least connect to it in a way public
transport public transportation is the
key to these concentrations of urban
mega cities like Mumbai is like Calcutta
is like Delhi and Jakarta and Lagos
Nigeria they think might be a city of 50
million people command in the next 20
years it would be that way
revitalization of the inner city some of
the projects Braga is doing or taking
old industrial properties and and
reclaiming it for higher density housing
which gives you the opportunity to have
transit oriented development and the
idea of having urban growth boundaries
it's very important that we don't have
the sprawl just continuing in any which
way it wants to go there has to be a
national policy and a state policy and
then right now in India the states all
control things in different ways and the
national policy is not really adequate
from what we can gather so those are the
things that we need in these long-term
visions we just came from Singapore
where they're there they plan as but as
as as well as anybody I've ever seen
they're doing a 45-year concept plan for
the year 2050 5 they've figured out what
they want to do and they've worked their
capital investments around that next
week 15 so let me pick up on this last
point you made about policy and in
directors particularly at frog but
is anybody doesn't chime in here let me
pose it this way to the developers you
work with get this and are they
interested in sustainable design and and
sustainable planning and if not or even
if they do what about local and state
officials are they are they embracing
this and are they developing the
policies they need to make it in in fact
on that we are very positive there is a
lot of work happening the great of work
is when we would wish policies can
implemented much faster before again the
growth pattern changes but there have
been various government initiatives to
look at you know much more efficient
buildings efficient cities I'll give you
an example the basic building level
codes there is now compliance on
environmental norms necessary mandatory
for large projects as far as city level
codes go we have recently Mumbai the
approach of the government has been to
encourage cluster development what what
we mean by kill you know rather because
earlier there was no difference whether
you develop one standalone building you
would get the same fer or you develop
ten buildings so it never led to it led
to pockets of development on wherever
you could now the government is in is is
promoting cluster development by giving
much more incentive for larger number of
plot owners to come together so that a
development could be planned you know
which which can create certain open
spaces for example in a city open spaces
where you will be able to plan in a much
more free manner than just within a plot
so there is movement at city level to
promote cluster redevelopment a large
parts of Mumbai are being there is top
of remaking of Mumbai Federation looking
at large parts of Mumbai getting
redeveloped in larger pockets rather
than smaller pieces of land as far as at
the state level or at the centre level
goes we have the energy code coming in
place which is voluntary for the first
two years and then it becomes compulsory
when links have to comply with an energy
code we will look at time so when there
will be an energy audits
and like you have start labeling for
electronic devices we buildings will be
labeled and then those who are
responsible will be rewarded and also
want will have to face penalties so
there is a lot of there is a lot of
movement to understand this issue if you
if you develop new cities again there is
incentive for eco housing so there is
the government has recognized these
issues fairly positively I use the mic
okay what is the word presidents one of
the area of interest yeah it is water
resources because is a coup shortage of
water this summer we may not have a
water there is a big moment for rain
harvesting which Barack can you look
great and the local government and
municipal corporation is already
involving it is one area I know where
you're a walk is being done and is going
to be done other area which would be of
interest to the Dean Carter would be in
the area of transportation I would like
to know today here in this panel how
many people have reached here by public
transport can I have the show of hands
please only one my POC down we took the
elevator I down from I left my office in
Santa Cruz East around quarter to six
went to my residence in santa cruz west
and left at five minutes past six I was
here ten minutes before seven by taking
a fast train which took it from Bandra
which stopped only at the other and
dropped me at nodded at judge good and
of course both the place i will take a
taxi and most of the mumbai commutes
like this Oh
the sale of cars in the last five years
in this country has been explosive
almost all the new development has been
auto oriented do you have an extended
transit lines or bus lines to those
places the middle growing middle class
all wants to have a car maybe two cars
can't park them there's no place in the
city to park them so it's a big issue
we're going to ask them other question
well actually this is a building on that
okay in your business in your profession
does a country any country stand out in
terms of being enlightened and
progressive when it comes to urban
design especially either through policy
or both a certain certainly Singapore
it's just having been there and meeting
with the Urban Redevelopment Authority
it's quite organized and progressive I
think a lot of the Scandinavian cities
are quite well planned and there are
many of the European cities or transit
oriented and walkable communities
although if you look on the outskirts of
Paris the outskirts of any of those
European cities there they're also
creating big shopping malls and
standalone office parks and things that
are not sustainable and partly it's
driven by demand market demand of middle
class wants to have the car wants to go
to the shopping mall but the cores of
those cities are quite livable and awe
and are not Auto dependent they're
really walkable and the lessons learned
in places like that would be portable to
a much bigger city like Mumbai yes
absolutely and but the transport systems
the the the idea of building more
housing a variety of housing I mean to
think of forty percent of the population
living
what you can see in the slums that has
to be dealt with but the country only
has limited resources right so that's
why the visionary plan needs to be in
place what do we do first what do we do
second and it's it's a it's a big burden
to carry not with the way Bombay shaped
I mean you have water on the other side
you can't grow except not and there is
an inertia to move seats of power seats
of law business away from the south of
Mumbai the issue gets compounded daily
with people coming all the way down to
South Mumbai whether it's public
transport or private transport where you
could digits like smart growth policies
that CMU advocates you could
decentralize even you can change the
zoning or land use could be made much
more efficient by which you could you
don't need even you you don't need to
add to the transport problems just
because you can't shift from a place to
the other also because of the way you
can't grow there is a lot of demand on
all the remaining land which is left
involving to become buildable it is you
know the city grows whatever we do it's
an economic issue and there is a demand
so much on land that slowly we are
losing our historic areas areas which
are culturally rich just because of the
pressures of development and it smart
growth looks at making alternate use of
lands making mix choose policies all
these would help reduce the pressure on
mainland city land and the one of the
theories that I'm seeing in some of the
journals in Indian planning journals is
the idea is that the smaller cities
really should absorb the growth that the
mega cities have had it I mean you can't
go too much more than they are but there
are something like 20 or 30 cities in
India that are more than a million
population and many of them could absorb
growth and so there's there's that
thought that maybe of a multinuclear
region where you have town centres and
viable smaller towns then try to absorb
everything in four or five big mega
cities
yeah don't be shy yes subject here
ghosts are over here with Sanjay go
ahead please send it yeah you know all
this is extremely interesting and all
that but I think the basic problem in
India is you have to have the political
will to implement these programs and I
think the entire sustainability issue
really in India in particular revolves
around you know how the politicians and
those in power view the you know the
situation with regard to their
electability and you know one of the
reasons that we have all these slums is
because the slums are the vote banks of
the parties and the party is in power
will never get rid of these slums in you
know you may organize all sorts of other
developments for them but unless they
have this vote bank they'll never get
reelected government ID says I mean if
you see Singapore public housing is
still the responsibility of the
government it you know it controls the
speculation in the market and it
provides quality housing stock here the
model is more to shift the
responsibility onto private developers
enter into private partnerships and an
abdication of responsibility of actually
being the providers for public housing
our delivery systems are weaker you know
the quality of the product that the
government delivers is not up to mark so
therefore is this this whole issue of
will later if you invite developers to
be your partners for public housing I
mean it goes against the whole idea of
affordability and making affordable
housing for the masses which actually in
other countries is it still the
responsibilities taken by the government
so he's right in the sense that you know
if there is a will a lot more could be
done for in these issues fall for the
math in general but I think it is
five years ago yes for 10 years ago and
the progress has been slow at least it's
a dialogue having and there are some
models to point to and say at least
we've tried it here and there's there's
an economic benefit to sustainable
design that's a broad nose quite well
you don't look convinced sungeum but
that you know one thing that has to be
observed is of course these issues are
highly political everywhere in the world
I mean there's no place you can't do
these things without as they say in
American English goring someone's ox
someone is going to lose or they'll be
perceived as being is losing and
someone's going to perceive as being as
having one and so it's inherently
political but it does require agree
completely at some point he requires
political leadership someone to stand up
and basically risk their political
careers on achieving this kind of
promise that's certainly true yeah Jared
Avila get enough now I was talking
earlier with some of the people i ended
up at CMU and walk and multidisciplinary
group called transportation research and
I had decided to come back and I was
interviewed by a number of very few
people wanted to come back and no in
fact it was a story in 1970 I was
interviewed by two government
organization that both of them gave me
very good offer one was indian space
research organisation but i didn't want
to work for a pro-government the second
was a silk oh and i was interviewed in
washington DC by sheer spittle and mr.
de Souza who were instrumental and I
listened to them because I was from
Carnegie Mellon University we had total
multi disseminate multidisciplinary
multinational group which was there and
thinking always was to look at
transportation problem in totality
as Dean Carter said that it has to be
seen in totality and these people were
planning a city in New Bombay and the
first thing I asked that what about
transportation link because just now I
said few minutes back that took for 25
to 50 minutes for me to reach here city
of Mumbai runs on the trains rapid
transit they said no we don't want to
put a rapid transit between Mumbai to
new Mumbai we wanted to stand alone and
all of us who are lewd here can see
ultimately they have to put it and now
they are going to extend it but it's
very late again in 71 I had detailed
presentation with railway ministry to
have underground transportation at least
to connect churchgate and VT and extend
VT a link all the way to Calabar and
went had a presentation nothing much
came out of it again now in the current
radio budget the minister for transfer
rate ways she is planning feasibility
study steal him after nineteen seventy
we are in year 2010 feasibility study
between the two station that is seat
city station churchgate annuity and we
are just going to talk about it and
second important point which parag
mentioned overmix usage there is so much
or land locked right from here all the
way to a about 15 kilometer called
bombay port trust that land is not used
at all it is just lying like that we can
have a garden a park stretching from
here all the way there public housing
private housing schools colleges
whatever we want there is no villain and
some young members of CMU illumination
should take up this issue so thank you
the one observation that comes out of
this and a truism mode all the things
you guys work on is that they take a
very long time even if you don't have
sort of the kind of political upsets
that are experienced in time to time
they just take a long time especially
transportation projects infrastructure
of any kind is just the long live long
planning cycle so all this observation
about political leadership and clinical
will has to be sustained to it can't
just be in a moment in time other
questions or comments last one this
question is for Barack gap you know
there's a there's a statistic that's
thrown around that by 2020 the
population of Mumbai about sixty percent
of the population of Mumbai will be
living in slums at this rate of
urbanization do you foresee that
sustainable development can coexist with
the need for public housing in a
cost-effective manner to need meet our
needs sustainable development is the
only solution because to have
development which is only targeted to a
section of the society will not let the
city grow or will not let the city
absorb growth so a sustainable city
policies like smart growth looks at a
much more broader spectrum where as he
said we look at even social
sustainability so if it is if any
development is sustainable it should be
accessible to all it is not just the few
green platinum related buildings that
that make a city sustainable or a few
fuel efficient cars that make the
transport system sustainable so if the
strategies which CMU is taking first
steps in like smart growths save all
city development applied to sustainable
city development you will see I mean
that is the only option left I mean I
don't think we will have in five years
to sell a concept
as an architect to a client let's talk
of sustainability it will by default be
integrated with other environmental
issues social issues which affect a
larger number of populist otherwise you
will have social divides you will have
gated communities for the super rich in
the slum still remaining by the site so
unless and the City Planning looks at
this issue holistically I don't think is
the people in this room I mean it's you
and it's the people you network with and
the people you do business with are
going to make this happen and it
reminded me of something at Carnegie
Mellon bill McDonough who was a very
famous architect the United States one
of the pioneers and sustainable
development came to give a lecture and I
was asked to introduce him to the
lecture at the lecture and he started
off his lecture unbelievably here's
another Native American quote that he
said and started off his lecture it was
what we have is because someone stood up
before us but our seventh generation
will have is a consequence of our
actions today so that's kind of a but
then he followed that with a statement
that I'll never forget this was must
been 20 years ago he said seven
generations ago in the united states was
the generation of George Washington
Thomas Jefferson Benjamin Franklin and
he said what will the seven general
seventh generation ahead of us think of
what we're doing right now on this earth
and that's so profound so profound and
so we have to do something they just say
you have to do something
no this is such a great note to end on
I'm not going to I'm not going to allow
any more questions or comments when
we're done here of course we're going to
go back to the reception and I know
they'd love to continue the conversation
that was a great note then on we we
clearly have just scratched the surface
of what is a very large and very
important challenge problem for Mumbai
for India and for the world we're very
proud of Carnegie Mellon I'm proud of
Carnegie Mellon of the role that we
played in developing the ideas a
sustainable design and educating the
people that are doing it bringing it to
the world please join me in thanking our
two panelists don carter and prog rock